end of the hierarchy was
bounded that trigger or ac0 fragrance on
next speaker Killian richer will tell us
about the latest news in some uh lower
bounds for uh under the frigate proofs
okay then please take it away yeah
thanks for inviting me
this will be a bit more technical than
the previous stocks I'm sorry about this
then it's trying to work with Johan one
of my I don't know you see my ex
advisors to advisor I don't know when he
was my advisor until like last fall so
yeah okay so just to give you a picture
again of where we are so right we have
resolution here and then we have this
like hierarchy of logic uh fruit systems
so we have for SK and then we have rest
login then we have found the depth and
extended
uh then we have like one semi-algebraic
proof systems a cutting planes and here
we have like the algebraic proof systems
and polynomial calculus and if we go
really crazy we can consider improved
systems such as ideal group system
which are very strong
but you really just know like lower
bounds for CNF formulas for these
somewhat weak proof systems so though I
was very happy that Robert referred to
on the fake as a strong proof system so
I'm going to show you how to prove lower
bounds for this strong proof proof
system on the depth trigger thank you
so yeah so
yeah I'll I'll first introduce like
frege State our results and then try to
give you some idea of how to retouch
Arizona
okay so how should we think of the
frigate proof system so it's just a
sequence of of Boolean formulas over
some basis uh will use or and not but
because I don't want to torture you I'll
use this shorthand called end
for not or not and then we can like
write out like a blue mean formula here
so so it's tree like if we ignore the
leaves where the variables live and yeah
you can assume that it's or not or end
and so on alternating and this circuit
happens to compute X1 okay or no formula
and then each line we have to derive it
right so or it's the cost so either we
take a clause from our original CNF or
we derive
a new moving formula from two or a
constant number of previous Boolean
formulas
and for this we have to do use these
derivation rules it's not so important
what they are precisely like somehow as
long as every derivation rule depends
only on a constant number of assumptions
like all these systems
simulate each other uh but this is one
proof system that we may consider it's
like somehow the first four rules are
kind of boring they just manipulate some
other structure of your formula and
really the interesting rule is this last
one which is a generalization of uh
the resolution rule so what does it say
well if you have a formula of the form Q
or P or q and P are formulas themselves
and you also have to formula not P or R
then you can actually like resolve over
p and not p and then you can derive Q or
R so you should really think of this as
like a generalized version of uh
resolution where we now can Branch over
more complicated objects
and because we want the
you want the reputation that the CNF has
a satisfying assignment we wanted the
final line is constant false so that
there are no satisfying sounds
standard size measures or measures to
reconsider so we have the length of a
proof which is the number of formulas
occurring in your proof we have the line
size which is the maximum size of any
formula in your proof
then we have the size which is just the
sum of the sizes of all formulas
occurring and the depth which is the
maximum logical depth of any formula
then like I mean one of the
long-standing open problems is to
actually prove like super polynomial
length floor bounds for freaky
reputations
unfortunately we really don't know what
to do about this or how to prove such a
such a lower bound and and what we do is
we somehow restrict all our proofs
namely we restrict our proofs to use
like only say constant depth formulas
okay
and that like to to demonstrate that
this is a real restriction like if you
take this circuit and you request or
require that it's more shallow well then
the size explodes right so so like
restricting the the size of the depth of
each formula May blow up the proof
considerably
okay
yeah like I'm assuming that I'm about to
setting because otherwise it's like
inconsistent that I can only talk about
so
yeah it's really it's really the logic
that that number of or not alternations
any other questions
so yeah so I also want to prove a lot on
four particular formula and we'll
replace the formula so what's the second
format
July is defined over graph connect the
graph we have two different variables
for every Edge and every vertex is
associated with an axiom claiming that
an odd number of edges incident to each
vertex is set to one okay so in
particular this is a satisfying
assignment while this one is not because
it like violates the vertex axioms at
these two points is there an even number
of edges
it's not so hard to show that the state
in Formula is satisfiable even only the
number of vertices is even
and so from now on we'll just assume
that our graphs always have an odd
number of vertices and in fact I'll fix
the graph that we'll consider we'll
consider the two-dimensional enzyme
Forest what do I mean by this well it's
this n
like this mesh defined over over a
two-dimensional donut say I'll not draw
this picture from now on but I'll like
put it into the plane and actually I'll
drop like the the edges wrapping around
because it's impossible to grow up so if
I draw a grid it's understood amount
that I actually talked about the Taurus
okay
and real quickly let me just tell you
what the kitchen or principle is well
he claims that n Plus on pigeon speed
into n holes so that every pigeon has
its own Hole uh normalize this by
introducing Boolean variables for each
pitch and hold pair with the intended
meaning that if it's actually true then
pigeon p goes to whole H every pigeon
claims Supply at least to one whole and
every hole is occupied by the most
advantage so just really quick I suppose
everyone uses
okay so some history so so what is the
game improving down the 33 kilograms so
we want to prove super polynomial
refutation size lower bounds for S deep
proof system as possible okay
so the first lower bound was by itai who
showed that for any constant that
trigger proof system these reputations
need to be of super prone learning size
and then this D was not explicit and
follow-up work then made it explicit to
to lock sorrow and still not very strong
but then this works by crycheck putlock
woods and it does
actually managed to extend this up to
that Vlog login
and we were really stuck at this step
for a long long time and like I'm gonna
ignore for now the developments on the
taking side and now like really since
the last few months like yeah hosts that
managed to actually push this round up
to that Vlog like
on The Dating side if you look you look
at the setting formula like there was
Spencers and work hard in late 90s who
considered it setting from London they
showed it after that local event this
was after these papers
and this was done by a really nice work
was extended to like that login and this
was the first one to get this that so
right yeah it really just worked that
the first time like this kind of Vlog
and that's
and then hostad actually also closed
this line of work off by his login or
log living but
and these are essentially all the lower
bounds we had for for bump adapter 3
game if we restrict ourselves as DNS and
their proof by the same technique like
we have one technique to prove it and
nothing else
so please develop new techniques
it's unbearable
so yeah but okay so let me uh go like
tell you what uh what's that actually
true so he showed that any fragrant
reputation of the statement principle
defined over this two-dimensional and
bind Forest if if these reputations are
restricted to that speed then these
require a size exponential n to the 1
over 58d
and
you cannot hope for a significant
Improvement on the dependence on D in
the second exponent if you would do this
we would get regular ones okay so at
least in my mind this was all that
like like I don't see any way how to
improve this interest I mean like an
interesting manner
and
then
came along and ask this beautiful
question of well we can restrict the
depth of each line but we could also
restrict the size of each line right
so what happens then can we improve
actually stronger low volumes
you should do this I think this is
really cool I I was surprised that you
can do this so so if you restrict the
the lines not just to Deputy but also to
line size and then you get these
exponential in N divided by some factors
just to illustrate the the
parameters like if you restrict the line
size to be polynomial in m
then this lower bound is like almost
fully exponential in them up to depth
like square root log n whereas the
previous lower bound that I showed you
as soon as D is growing function in N
then the lower bound is the form of
exponential entity law of one so these
lower bonds are much much stronger okay
and they conjecture that this is
actually not the end of the story and
one should be able to to improve this
lower bounds to be exponential and N
over log Nativity yeah
so yeah our result our main result is is
basically resolving this uh conjecture
and we showed that indeed like like such
refutations require this length
and just to give you again the feeling
for parameters so now we can go in quasi
polynomial line size as well as up to
that slogan over log login and we still
get this almost fully exponential uh
lower models on the length of
reputations
previous slide
and
because the circuits Computing
sorry yes I think so the question is why
do we have to do minus one here at this
moment and because
the lower bound this is kind of the tied
upper part yes and
we don't have a real syntactic proof but
we have a if you consider
somewhat that's a semantic proof system
then the new connection this should be
there it comes really from from under
that X or lower bouncy where you also
have an exponential in end of the one
over
thank you
yeah I I believe we get D minus one here
if I write a polylogan here
okay and along the way we actually
improve this uh size lower round
of hosted to be exponential and N to the
one over D minus one which previously
was empty 1 over 58b it's a big
Improvement but this should be now tight
I don't have proof that this type it
should be tight because this is the size
that you need in Deputy to represent an
xor over n variance
and then suppressing probably a lot of
factors
questions
and you know we don't have any mentioned
I mean we have a construction of the
semantic proof which that chooses but uh
so yeah all the lines here are really
formulas right he's like yeah so you're
not like allowing like you could imagine
like bounded depth applications of the
extension Rule and that could shrink it
even more right yeah our lower one also
applies for for circuits
actually distinguishes but I mean
because we we have a holy Lord here
but like we cannot see this different
yet but like it would be nice to
actually get like expansion or whatever
yeah I don't know how to combine
rosman's
like notion of this time
thank you
okay
some ideas how to prove cycle routes
so um yeah so yeah we talked already
about the depth circuits so it shouldn't
be so surprising that we actually use
Machinery developed to prove uh on the
depth circuit robots so let me like
really really like give a really rough
outline of how these argument goes
so what do we do well suppose we've
given a small circuit of that c that
computes barely on methods
then we want to hit the circuit C with
the description row that keeps each
variable a life with probability key
meaning it does not assign it and with
probability one minus P each variable
independently sets it to zero or one
uniform addresses
and then you want to argue that oh under
this restriction my my circuit actually
shrinks in depth by one
and then I repeat these three times that
I'm left with the constant circuit
Computing constant but hopefully my my
function is still non-constant
the main technical setting in actually
they're like completing it is
so let me tell you what we're switching
gamma does so would would the statement
of the switching gamma guarantees you is
that if you take a dnf with bottom
planning bounded by T and you hit it
with the Restriction row then you can
write this rewrite this formula as a
CNN
with bottom timing hypnosis
okay so F under row can be represented
as a CNF with low volume
and then there is some failure
probability like of the randomness of
your choice row that this actually does
not happen and by a classic result of
course that you can actually download
This by by something that is independent
of them
I still think
and yeah then just how do you apply this
well you look at the bottom two layers
you switch them applying this switching
Lemma and then you can collapse the
those layers and you're like that e
minus one and
so we want to apply this Machinery to
frigate proofs okay
so how do we do this
this is actually not how the proof goes
but that's
pretend we can do this so we hit the
fragrance reputation with a restriction
rule so that the depth of every line
shrinks by one but this is not all but I
also have to guarantee is that I don't
suddenly introduce contradiction in my
initial format right like if I hit my
formula by this restriction I don't want
to have contradiction already in my
formula because then it becomes very
easy to review this conversation so I
additionally need to guarantee that I I
can like maintain the structure of my
original form and this is somehow where
all the complications arrive do you
really want to go from a large take an
instance to this model
and yeah again you prove a switching
gamma
let's carry all the details but the
original proof of hot stuff somehow
managed to get this failure probability
with this s27 it turns out that you need
to reunion bound over all subformulas
occurring in your proof so you need this
to be less than one over
the inverse of the size of your proof
and this s27 really like caused this
only second exponent like potentially
mental 1.58 and our new proof now
manages to replace this by a login
instead of this
and then yes against two sets we get
these six management
yes okay certainly true that what you've
just said that if you uh introduce
contradictions it becomes easy because
you can have outcome I don't know I mean
like you violate an accent of the day
like like us you said an even number of
variables to zero next
the contradiction it's the fact that
it's easy complication
yes I have to like maintain the hardness
for a supposed to hurt myself
like
okay so yeah so this was for the science
that rebound and then I also should
maybe tell you something about our main
result how one proves it so
here we we really follow uh pedestrian
Krishna and pan they show that you can
use multi-switching another emotion from
switching terminology to prove these
frigate trade-offs which is really
surprising because now the switching was
devised to actually get these coronation
upper bounds per circuits
very circuit
and you but it turns out that this is
also useful to prove these trade-offs
like line size versus length
results
so we have to prove multitude so I'll
try to explain to you again what the
main what the statement is
so first the switching magnet guarantees
you actually something better it does
not just happen you can go from dnf to
CNF but it tells you that you can go
from a dnf into a bounded that decision
tree so what is the decision tree you
query a variable X depending on its
value
and now if you remember from the proof
outline we had to do this Union bound
over all subforms of operation proof and
we didn't want to not do that we want to
do something smart so what is a
reasonable thing to do well you could
consider many dnfs together at once
right and then analyze somehow then
having some object and then say
something
and then what is
it tells you that if you consider many
dnms then you can
under this restriction rule represent
them as the following you represent them
as a partial common decision tree or
founded depth and then each dnf that you
consider has like these small decision
trees hanging off this partial decision
tree so that the combination of this
large tree and these small trees
actually decide your
dnf under this restriction okay so for
different uh
dnfs you have these small decision trees
like language they're large partial
conversations
and then now again you can like analyze
the failure probability if it's
happening and it turns out that you can
bound it by this expression which is
essentially the same failure probability
might not accept this factor which is
due to the construction
so
okay
so I'm how much time do it
let's say four or five minutes four or
five minutes okay
so
yeah but like all the fun in these
proofs happens in how you design this
restriction but like this restriction
how you choose this it's like really
important so I at least not just tell
you what this restriction is and what it
does and giving you an idea of how it
starts
so we use the same restriction or
essentially the same restriction to this
whole stuff and the security paper and
yeah just to remind you what you want is
to start with taking instance of a large
space and you want to end up with the
states and instance over a smaller group
and what we do is we hit the proof with
a f fine restriction meaning that we
every original X variable we either set
one zero or a new variable or a negation
of the error
so how do we come up with such a
restriction so first we hit the entire
proof with the Restriction setting every
Edge one or zero so that the vertices
should survive have an even number of
ones next to them and all others have an
odd number of ones next
so so and then we like want to really
represent this as a variable y for pi
for each path and what you do is we
replace like negative things by the
negation of the corresponding variable
and positive things the positive things
along this path
and we do this
you get this restriction and this is the
Restriction that we use and yes it's
nice property with any vertex on the
path you can verify that under any
assignment to the Y variables you
actually have an all number of ones next
to it and these vertex accents that have
still the same form of an X so you're
really left with this smaller instance
right what is a fine restriction and
this seems like just a restriction
yeah yeah it's the Restriction would
substitute so why is it fun
well I mean it has to respect negations
or I don't know it's a name that people
have chosen and I'm just reusing I I do
not fully agree
okay so this was the Restriction now I
have to tell you how to actually choose
the software Solutions okay
so we start with the smart script and we
want to end up with this mode
and you could just like pick any like
subgrid and choose this as a restriction
but the issue is that you get a lot of
dependence between nodes like which one
you choose and so on and you want to
prevent this so so what you do is first
you like cut your your whole grid into
smaller pieces and you guarantee that
you pick one vertex from each separate
so sudden you get independence in a
sense which is important
and then again as we form we pick a
solution to the formula where the Blue
Notes now have an even constraint so
this is now a satisfying instance and
then we connect them by some paths in a
very careful manner it's not important
what this precisely is and then we
connect them and we end up with this
like smaller ports okay
and actually
in the main issue with this is that if
you look at this restriction it's very
easy to find these nodes because these
are just the nodes that have an even
constraint all others satisfy the old
constraints
so we want to obfuscate this and
therefore we need to intermitt
restriction to height where these new
notes are what you do is like you pick
two furnaces in adjacent sub squares and
you connect them by a path it fits the
value along this path so that these also
have an even constraint
and then we do this a bunch of times
you can somehow let's do this
restriction or at least pretend to have
this restriction and the main property
that we have is now that it's difficult
to tell whether to be known is this one
this one this one or this one so somehow
we use this
[Applause]
and yeah the key difference like for
anyone who has ever at these groups the
key difference is that previous
restrictions have roughly as many uh
such vertices in English subscore and we
now have lower
one limitation of this technique very
annoying
is that we need to assign a huge number
of of variables for for one
step
and so this means that we can only apply
this technique to these formulas that
are almost satisfying or like minimally
unsatisfied and we cannot apply them to
like formulas that are only locally so
it's fine let's say random cnfs
so yeah that's it for me so just
reiterate or improved so so if you have
mind size and that c we get this
expansion and over log into the D and if
you only respect to that speed then we
get this expansion and one OD
some open problems I think I listed them
like from easy to hard let's see so the
first one is that our lower bound is
somehow exponential in the square root
of the number of variables because this
formula has N squared many variables
can we actually get a lower one that is
exponential in N to the one over D with
n variables so like improving like a
square root and like an obvious
candidate to try is at least to try this
rotation over this matter
I think this might get broken
the next question which is due to human
films actually and it's a question that
you asked me for it's like our lower
bounds cannot distinguish whether you
have formulas or circuits of low damage
on each line and can you actually make
this like distinction in a sense like
yeah proof this exponentially D times n
to the one over
and then yeah like really nice problems
but I have no idea what to do uh proof
the bump that regular bumps for like
supposedly hard formulas such as like
the true table totality uh click or
random scene I just don't know
[Applause]
okay down
is there really a way to actually run
these constantly spread the lower bounds
without the proof studio so just who you
have a specific properties of the
solution and the pathology unique
without discussing this
soon
enough
you just have a set of properties that
you need your switching to Denmark to
provide
that's it and then this will basically
reduce the problem with constant depth
to switching them or to a circular
is it correct
is there a way my understanding is in
constant depth rate improves at least
the way it has did it you don't need to
analyze the proof you just need to have
a set of of statement of properties for
the switching level and then you say
from known result K evaluation and so
forth I get a lot is it correct yes okay
now I think I understand the question so
the question is whether we need to
analyze the structure of the proof in
order to apply or switching them and no
we do not like we just apply switching
online
he can use better analysis for like say
circuits versus formulas but then some
proof Theory need to come into it
or do you think a strong enough
switching limit would just be able to
tell the difference like the Ross Smith
In Style so
Robert is asking whether
whether uh
had to come in for 40 seconds
I I really don't I just I mean just
about trying to apply this Rossman like
this notion of time
yeah
do you think there is some kind of a
super critical regime where you should
expect one of the parameters too much
the other parameters go out
what it is
the question is whether
it's uh
existing training you can balance that
option we can also be responded trigger
but yeah I believe yes okay
okay yeah another half percent sure I
know you can do it
yeah you have to pay a little bit for
the depth like go up a little bit
so let's uh thank the speaker again
and then we reconvene at 2 pm for an
afternoon of more uh applied talks on
the algorithmic side of of
complexity
continuing our discussion on algorithmic
aspects